pop star et on avait créé un groupe
justement pop star ça s'appelle et link
justement il y avait matt pokora il y
avait au tice est-ce qu'on a un extrait
d link
vous
des gens
c'est un boys band magnifique qui
chantent très très bien jusqu'au bout
nous entendre la troisième des ventes en
france sorti en novembre 2003 album
certifié d'or plus de deux cent mille
exemplaires vendus premier single
certifié dehors aussi et puis en 2004 le
groupe prend fin parce que tout
simplement matt pokora décide de partir
pour une carrière solo et du coup bas
lionel essaie de faire aussi un petit
peu là la même chose est en réalité à ce
moment là on va dire la vérité c'est il
s'en va et c'est un peu la descente aux
enfers lionel ouais tu t'aperçois que
ton téléphone sonne plus que tu essaie
d'appeler été chargé de prod chez m6 qui
la veille te disais mon chouchou tout va
bien se passer tu dîne avec olivier
nusse qui étaient les patrons de la
trempe du lm tu te répondent toutes les
cinq minutes quand appel puis du jour au
lendemain y'a plus rien ça tenait
rapporter combien de faire les link up
les links ballon à l'époque c'était un
contrat m6 en coproduction avec m avec
universal donc en tout et pour tout j'ai
pris soixante dix mille euros 70000
euros pour wii plus de 200 mille albums
en fait là les chiffres c'était même
c'était avant mais on a vendu 750 mille
disques et on a été certifié triple
disque d'or voilà on va regarder un
extrait quand même parce que pareil tu
as fait un documentaire dans lequel tout
est livré ce jeu je trouve que tu es et
ce documentaire et aymeric à oublier les
caméras tu as tout dit a parlé de la
dépression et de tout regarder
le groupe s'arrête parce que ma part du
groupe et qui décide de faire une
carrière solo hélas mon là toi tu es là
tu regardes son ascension fulgurante
chimie moi je fais quoi moi à chaque
fois qu'ils en aient voir mon père
c'était pourquoi lui réussit et pas toi
même les gens dans la rue sont et seront
comme atari pas toi t'es un loser à
cette époque la carrière de matt pokora
s'envole lionel essaie lui aussi de
faire une carrière solo
mais pas assez
[Musique]
j'ai pas beaucoup d'argent c'est pas
j'ai pas gagner des sens et des 1001 va
pas se mentir et donc il faut vivre à
escota et j'ai vécu avec deux ans
deux ans et c'était juste j'étais en
galère
j'ai honte de moi
et est ce que j'avais à dire aussi ces
voix là parce que je l' ai vu faire
quand on reçoit matt pokora qui est
assis ici parce qu'il a fait une tournée
de tous les zéniths et tu es chauffeur
de salle pour applaudir et tacle au dit
aux copains si chaud horrible qu'est-ce
qu'on recensement voilà
une fois je la comprends parce que moi
je sui fra ger jeu temple je t'en prie
un
terreau pour ton amie à mes
fers shell
c'est complexe parce que ça te renvoie
en fait tu puisses et indépendante à
beaumont têtu tu te bats pour
tu te bats pour rester humble en fait
dire non c'est cool c'est normal la
vielle et dur il faut rester faut rester
fort était content pour lui et tu dis
est ce que cette poussière des toiles
qu'il a permis d'aller là où il est
pourrait pas d'avoir un petit peu pour
toi t'as pourrait pas retomber un petit
peu pour toi mais aujourd'hui je suis
heureux chez heureux de faire le métier
que je suis je suis content d'être avec
vous sur ses lecteurs a préféré ne
jamais la faire cette aventure non
aujourd'hui même si je souffre même
aujourd'hui voilà c'est un peu compliqué
je vais être honnête avec toi je fais
encore une psychanalyse je vais voir un
psy ça me coupe de l'aude reis et c'est
là tu te bats pour des projets là j'ai
décidé de monter une pièce de théâtre et
de parler de mon histoire d'une manière
un petit peu détournée dégoupiller à
chaque fois et je parle de tout ce que
j'ai vécu dans cette pièce là hé hé oui
et oui je me suis battu pour avoir ce
bébé là voilà ça c'est mon bébé
aujourd'hui je peux être fier que de ça
parce que j'ai emprunté pour produire
cette pièce là je joue à la divine comme
il dit pendant quarante cinq dates c'est
j'ai mis mes deniers j'invite tout ce
que je peux inviter pour pour l'on leur
montrer que bah finalement ya pas de
fatalité si tu veux vraiment y arriver
tu y arrives avec le sourire et même si
je fait applaudir le public pour matt
pokora je suis heureux de le faire parce
que ça lui donne de l'énergie et c'est
pareil pour tous les invités qui
viennent sur ce plateau là et emad juste
oui
et je tiens à préciser que personne ne
fait applaudir le public parce que c'est
lui normalement il est là donc et j'ai
posé une dernière question mais c'est
tellement touchant et sans aucune
méchanceté de matt pokora mnu il a fait
la star ac il a été par an il était là
tous les jours sur nrj 12 ça marchait
pas très bien j'adore ce gars sont
jamais dire de mal de lui est-ce que de
temps en temps il ya eu un petit coup de
fil il ya des textos d'anniversaire
honnêtement on a fait une aventure
ensemble on ne se connaissait pas vrai
ce n'était pas mon meilleur ami c'était
comme mon petit frère dans l'émission
j'ai pris sous son aile il est parti
s'est envolé il a une vie de famille il
a une entreprise à gérer c'est quelqu'un
qui a qui a des détourneurs a payé il a
plein de choses à faire je pense pas
qu'il ait le temps de m'appeler je sais
qu'il est très occupé il a déjà trois
enfants ados là et je pense que c'est
normal maintenant trois mois quand on se
croise il dit bonjour on se comprend des
nouvelles on se dit qu'on va les manger
ensemble et puis c'est tout puis après
j'attends réel lui en fait vraiment je
bosse je vais tout droit j'avance et je
fonce pour la pièce de théâtre un peu
plus
[Applaudissements]